[Music]
If you dare to get too close, you'll be able to miss the dance. It's
amazing how great Aberlem is,
Shion.
[Music] Logi. The
power of his slashing attacks is increasing, and he's
adjusting his stance in front of him. As expected of a genius
sword.
I'm tired, but I can't show my pathetic appearance in front of her.
This is the king's final battle. Please
stop now. We'll both really
die.
[Music]
Wow, my words won't reach you after all.
Everyone, please listen to my story
[Music]
Well, it's just like that time.
Words are
powerless in front of a person who has a sword and is determined to fight.Prince Shioabel, please, please, please.
So, will Mia's voice really make my wish come true?  I do
n't know if it's true or not, but I don't know. Even if
that voice doesn't reach the princes who hope for a bloody battle, the
bonds that I've realized will make her voice reach me.
Who are the people
she can rely on?
[Applause]  ] I
'm in trouble
[Music]
Hey, aren't you a bit too naughty,
uncle? My
princess is a crybaby, so I hope you
won't make her cry too much, Rion.